the rtx 3080 is the most powerful gpu
we've ever seen at this price point
but
we've said that before and in fact we
say it every time there's a new graphics
card generation so what makes this one
so darn special i mean the hype
surrounding it was so huge that even we
got caught up in it i mean look how
excited this guy is it's infectious but
as we all know
hype disappoints and absolute hype
disappoints absolutely
unlike our sponsor glassware glasswire
is the tool that shows you which apps
are slowing down your connection in real
time and it's used by security pros to
monitor for malware block bandwidth
wasters and detect suspicious activity
get 25 off today at the link below
[Music]
you hear that it's rattling
weird um while you read over our test
platform let me get this off of my chest
nvidia man you guys really went out of
your way to set yourselves up here
didn't you like i don't
get it spoiler alert you're shipping the
fastest graphics card on the market at
half the price of the previous king
why don't you just leave it there why
push your luck with claims like twice as
fast as rtx 2080 because it's not
[Music]
now
to be very clear it's not like i'm
saying you know burns 3080 biggest
disappointment ever
because right out of the gate at 1440p
we're looking at a performance lead over
not just the price comparable last gen
2080 but even the 2080 ti
and even with rtx disabled i mean this
is a freaking awesome leap in raw
horsepower
overall we saw anywhere from a 20 to 75
uplift over the 2080 with the biggest
benefits coming in directx 12 and vulcan
titles so then
the only reason i'm disappointed at all
is because nvidia told me to expect
double the performance of the 2080 which
as it turned out was anywhere from a
small embellishment to a fish this big
whopper but wait okay because perhaps
there's more to this
could our lackluster cs go performance
numbers hold the key
look how cpu-bound this game ends up
even at 1440p so let's kick it up a
notch to 4k where we're gonna leave out
our rx 5700 xt so we can test out dlss
nvidia's deep learning up sampling
technology and ooh is that
41 frames per second in microsoft flight
simulator at 4k ultra no less holy sh
i mean not only that but the minimum of
34 fps
that is perfectly playable in a game
that's more focused on visuals versus
fast movement which means that we can
definitively say yes it can run flight
sim 2020
like damn
now in general we're still not seeing
that 2x performance bump with results
closer to 75
but we're also still outpacing our rtx
2080 ti by anywhere from 10 to 30
percent and at 4k cs go really lets the
3080 flex its big gains in memory
bandwidth thanks to its 10 gigs of
gddr6x memory that is a very small drop
in performance compared to 1440p so
alright then while it may not be exactly
what nvidia promised us the 3080 is
still a gaming monster
maybe productivity will give us a
clearer understanding of what they meant
by that whole
double the performance thing
and yeah okay
that's double
and
well ahead of the rtx 2080 ti in fact in
blender the rtx 3080's cuda score is so
good that it rivals
excuse me scratch that beats the rtx
2080s rtx optimized optics render time
like
excuse me pardon and don't even get me
started on the 3080s optics times i mean
this
this is game-changing for students and
prosumers and even professionals looking
to build affordable and powerful 3d
rendering stations spec view perf does
bring us back down to earth somewhat
with performance that's more in line
with our gaming numbers which is a
bummer but at least it gives us a hint
as to where nvidia may have been
focusing when they came up with that
double figure
interestingly though team red pulled off
a couple of wins here too so while the
3080 tops the charts in most cases it's
not all powerful and amd's big navi
announcement next month could extend
some of those leads
now part of the rationale for choosing a
ryzen-based gpu test bench was so that
we could test pci express gen 3 versus
gen 4 starting with our review of the rx
5700 xt
unfortunately we had some
issues to exercise so that'll have to
wait for another day get subscribed so
you don't miss our deeper dive on pci
express gen 4. for now let's look at
power draw
using nvidia's pcat tool we captured
this data while running spec view perf
on our nvidia cards here and we can see
that the rtx 3080 is sitting roughly 100
watts higher than the rtx 2080 ti
impressively hitting a lofty maximum
above
350 watts
that is a lot of juice ladies and
gentlemen and if the trend continues it
definitely explains why nvidia felt they
needed this new 12-pin connector this
power draw translates into a significant
increase in heat output as you might
expect as well
but
it turns out the new founders edition
cooler design is nothing short of
incredible
in spite of it drawing a hundred watts
more our 3080 maintained lower
temperatures in a closed chassis than
our 2080 ti
and boosted to roughly two gigahertz
under full load throughout our testing i
mean
hey it's unconventional you know blowing
air up here and sucking air up through
there but gosh darn it it works at least
for the gpu itself
one small detail nvidia glossed over in
their marketing is that all of this heat
has to go somewhere and when we dug a
little deeper well by jove we found it
as it turns out dumping heat directly
into your cpu and ram makes them run
hotter we even made this little graph
where you can see system thermals
climbing by 10 degrees in a gentle arc
across the board indicating that it's
not just spec view perf putting a load
on these components or we'd be seeing a
spiky graph similar to our cpu and gpu
temperatures
there is good news though when we ran
the same test with a founder's edition
rtx 2080 ti we actually got even worse
results indicating that the more
efficient
system airflow that nvidia boasted about
for their cooler actually manages to
extend to the rest of the system as well
so
good job guys
and there's more to the story here than
performance and power alone nvidia has
become
laser focused on system latency as a way
to market their products even going as
far as to seed press with the internal
tools that they use to measure it and as
it turns out that's for good reason now
more frames per second does result in
smoother animations but since most
gamers would probably say 100 fps looks
butter smooth it's clear that this
smooth animations benefit has already
hit a wall of diminishing returns
what doesn't seem to have a limit yet
however is the effect of higher frame
rates on a gamer's actual performance
last year we demonstrated a benefit in
competitive play all the way up to 240
hertz in this video featuring shroud mr
grimms corey and paul's hardware so then
if the reason for this
improvement in gaming acumen isn't
smoother animations well what is it it's
the responsiveness of the system
the more often the image updates on
screen the less delay a gamer is going
to feel between the movement of their
mouse and the corresponding crosshair
making it easier to track down opponents
well nvidia reflex which is launching
today as well takes this research
nvidia's done and goes a step further
than even the ultra low latency mode
that's been enabled in both nvidia and
amd's drivers since last year and nvidia
has worked with developers to improve
rendering latency directly in the game
itself with a cpu-bound scenario it's
not exactly a big deal you're getting a
very slight improvement in response time
with a bit more consistency we're not
sure what that plus boost option is all
about but in fortnite anyway it doesn't
seem to do much at least at high frame
rates other games implementations may be
better nvidia says that reflex works
best in gpu bound loads anyway though
and in that scenario latency goes from
90 to 120 milliseconds to around 45 to
80 with reflex enabled that's huge one
of the biggest problems with a low frame
rate is low responsiveness so the small
sacrifice of one to two fps ends up
being a really good trade the best part
is that this feature works all the way
back to 900 series maxwell gpus
great stuff also revolutionary is rtxio
which uses the same direct storage
technology that microsoft is integrating
into the xbox series x and series x to
allow the gpu to stream and decompress
data directly from an nvme ssd using the
cuda cores from an rtx 2000 series card
or newer now we can't test this feature
yet because there are no games on the
market that support it yet but we would
expect gamers to see similar benefits to
what sony showed off with their
analogous technology with improvements
to everything from texture resolution in
game to even level design eliminating
things like unnecessary elevator rides
while the assets load in
but wait there's more
what we also can't test is the reports
that all ampere-based cards support
sriov at a hardware level for the
uninitiated sriov allows a single gpu to
be shared between multiple virtual
machines never mind two gamers one gpu
with performance like this you could run
a whole freaking lan center off a single
threadripper 3990x and like
four of these i mean this would be a
monumental shift from nvidia considering
that they've locked down g-force and
virtual machines since
basically forever or at least it would
be
nvidia clarified with us that the
reports of their change of heart were
sadly overstated and as it turns out
just because they can support the
feature doesn't mean that it's enabled
and sure enough when we fired up our
3080 and linux it didn't report any sri
ov capabilities nvidia does say though
that the final decision on whether to
enable it or not has yet to be made so
it is still possible they'll enable it
maybe if enough people tweeted them
jensen will get the hint wink wink not
just please in summary then
just like last time we have no way of
testing some of the headline features
and no time to test others like nvidia
broadcast which we'll be sure to do a
follow-up video on but unlike last time
the raw performance and pricing are
compelling enough story on their own
even if nvidia overplayed their hand a
little
and unlike last time the big feature you
know
the one that's right in the name the
hardware support for real-time ray
tracing has had a couple of years to
mature with a much longer list of
supported games to go along with
graphics cards that are now actually
powerful enough to turn the feature on
without tanking the frame rate to be
clear it's still not the kind of thing
that i would personally buy a new card
over but as far as added bonuses go
raytraced minecraft is
pretty sweet
and if you're looking for a segue to our
sponsor this is it
do you think making a website is hard
well it doesn't have to be use
squarespace and you'll have your website
up and running in a matter of hours
maybe even faster they've got
award-winning templates that'll help
make your website stand out instead of
looking like it's from the 90s and if
you're interested in how your website's
performing they've got built-in tools to
help you find out what you're doing
right and what you're doing wrong both
our linus media group and ltx expo
websites were built quickly using
squarespace and if you get stuck making
your site they have a 247 support team
that's ready to help you out just go to
squarespace.com ltt and you can get 10
off today we're going to have that
linked below
so thanks for watching guys if you're
looking for more ampere go check out our
post announcement explainer on ampere
for a little bit more background info
and a little more context for all the
hype
hey i didn't mention lttstore.com
go to lttstore.com buy stuff
we got water bottles
and graphic card shirt
oh yeah that too